[Narrator:] In 1900 bubonic plague was
epidemic in theports of Asia.
Its mode of transmission was not understood. Whencases surfaced in San Francisco the Chinese people
were held accountable. Chinatown was cordoned off. Homes and businesses were fumigated and destroyed.
Plague was termed an "Oriental disease" peculiar to "rice-eaters" and moves were made to quarantine all
of the Chinese. The city health officer alsolaid smallpox at the feet of what he called,
"the unscrupulous lying and treacherous Chinamen" in their dark and dingy quarters. Leprosy, too
was considered an inherently Chinese disease,transmitted to whites via opium pipes. Fear and
prejudice intensified by uncertainty, can easilyoverride sympathy for those affected by such adisease.
[Female Patient:] Everybody thought I was going to die andall them doctors and everything was around my bed.
I remember the priest giving me last rites andyou know I prayed and prayed to, you know....
Don't take me out right now because I still wantto see my family grow up and my grandkids and all
that, you know. They came to tell me about going upto the ward where they keep those people, you know.
And I didn't want to go up
there because I was thinking, God
people gonna know. I don't want nobody to know, because people don't understand
about this sickness. They just treat
you like you got a plague or something.
You cannot be yourself. You can't let nobody know.You have to live a life, a very secretive life.
[Male Patient:] Well, I thought I got it from a female. Which I still think to this day. The lady was a prostitute, okay,
and I felt that I'd come in contact with itthat way, because she did tell me this, you know.
That she had tested positive. I was whisked awayto a very far corner of the jail.  I was isolated
away from everyone. I was not allowed contactwith anyone. I was not allowed to use the phone.
I had to slip a message out to have someonecall the American Civil Liberties Union and
have an attorney come see me. So I couldget out of the cell.
[George Simons:] Shanti Project thisis George. Have you ever used, uh Shanti services before? Okay, you want to hold on a moment please?
Shanti Project, can you hold please?
[Narrator:] In Hinduscripture, Shanti is a word for celestialpeace. Sometimes repeated as an incantation.
[George:] ShantiProject, can you hold please? Thank you for waiting, may I help you?
[Narrator:] At the Shanti Project in San Francisco, dispensing celestial peace can be nerve-wracking.
The organization is a counseling centerfor people with AIDS.
[George:]  We're averaging around6,000 calls a month and I answer themall.
[George:] Shanti Project, this is George.
Jana,hi, this is, it's an intake please. He's a littledistressed. Sometimes it's difficult and you just
kind of have to um hope that there's a pause sothat you can kind of take a deep breath and go on.
Because sometimes you hear things
that you know are a little unsettling.
[Charles Herrington:] Yes, thanks.
[Narrator:] To the Shanti staff, funeralarrangements, emergency places to live, and suicidecounseling are everyday requests. Callers areoften distraught.
[Charles:] Is your will a simple affair?In other words, are we dealing with, what is now a real basic estate?
[Narrator:] Many of the diseases that strikepeople with AIDS, such as pneumocystis pneumonia,
can be grim in their later stages. Shanticounselors do not advocate suicide, but will
refer people to the Hemlock Society which provideshow-to information about voluntary euthanasia.
[George:] Well I just had a call from somebody that Iknow who it is, and he doesn't realize who Iam.
And um, he's asking for, well, Neptune Societyand Hemlock Society. [Staff member:] You gonna call him back?
[George:] No...the funny part of it is I really feel likeI have to treat it as a confidential thing.
[Staff:] You know the individual socially? [George:] Umhmm,
[Staff:] You could approach him from a social angle
[George:] Ithink that's what I'll do. If he's willing to waitfor information about the Hemlock Society, he's
probably not planning to do anything right away.
[Staff:] Do I know who it is? [George:] Probably. [Staff:] I don't want toknow.
[Man speaking to group:] You know, many people with AIDS or manypeople that are going through the dyingprocess are obnoxious and very demanding...
[Narrator:] Hundreds of people come to Shanti asvolunteers. The public in general is fearful of
people with AIDS, and that fear is often compoundedby a lack of sympathy springing from the fact that
the virus is spread mainly among homosexuals anddrug addicts. Most of these volunteers, however,
know someone who has AIDS or someone who has died, orhave themselves tested positive for the virus.
They are training to help patients and their familiesthrough the emotional turmoil of the disease.
[Speaker to group:] It's also very difficult when you prepare yourself for your loved one to die and then they don't die.
You know, the respirations start to slow downand you think oh god you know, it's gonna be
maybe in 48 hours. The next day it's even worse andyou think well maybe it's going to happen and then
you totally give them that last amount of your energy and then suddenly the next morning
they rally, they're feeling good and you think, oh my god,how am I going to do this for another two months?
You know and that's hard stuff to talk about.
[Narrator:] Atthese training sessions one of the instructors isBobby Reynolds, a native San Franciscan.
His parents are dead and his only close relative is a sister. In 1982 his doctor diagnosed himwith Kaposi's Sarcoma, Skin Cancer,
one of the primary diseases that strike peoplewith AIDS.
[Bobby:] I expected that he would tell meeverything was fine over the phone, when in fact hesaid I'm sorry, it's positive.
So I went into shock. Living with AIDS these past four years has beenan incredible experience. I treasure the lessonsthat I have learned.
[Narrator:] Today Bobby Reynolds is a
rarity. The life expectancy of a person with AIDS
is about 18 months, but chemotherapy successfullycontrolled his cancer. He has become a prominent
advocate of the rights of people with AIDS, allthe while mindful that with his immune system
damaged by the virus, his body is defenselessagainst any disease that may come along.
[Bobby:] What is, right now is I'm doing pretty good, and what'spossible is a lot, you know, there's a lot possible.
[Speaker 2:] When I was first diagnosed, people gave me, youwouldn't believe some of the stuff, coffee enemas
[Laughter]
[Bobby:] They need someone to hang their hope on, they need to to have somebody to be a role model
for them and I think I have been able to dothat.
[Speaker 2:] And so beyond dealing with your decision about how you want to be, you end up having to deal with all this other stuff that's out there.
[Susan:] I told my brother before I got pregnant that, youknow, I wasn't sure how things would be between us,
because I didn't want to take any chanceswith my kids. Every doctor I talked to said
that I shouldn't have any contact with
my brother because they just don't know.
[Rodney:] It was the kind of thing, well ifnobody can tell us what's going on,
then uh gee you know, what are you supposed to do?
[Narrator:] Although they live just a few miles apart, Bobbyand Susan have scarcely seen each other in thetwo and a half years since her twin boys were born.
[Susan:] I told him that I would try and keep in touchwith him on the phone which I did, and every week
it would be like he'd get a little cooler and wefinally just more or less cut off communications.
He told me that it was like I had rejected himand he just couldn't deal with it right now,
and I couldn't do much about it because I figuredhey you know, I'm pregnant, I'm not gonna
get pregnant again, I can't take any chances. I don'twant anything to happen to my baby.
[Bobby Reynolds:] Hundreds ifnot thousands of people have heard me speak andwere able to look at AIDS through different eyes.
And I have touched men in support group andI have touched their families and I have been
able to help them find some ways of dealing andand you know, she's my sister.
[Rodney:] He'd like Sue to beable to just jump and go, but... [Susan:] With three kids andRod, I can't, it's just not possible...
[Rodney:] I mean, it's family first and unfortunately he'sfamily too but it's immediate family
andthen it's the rest of the family.
[Susan:] I realize that they say casual contact, you probably wouldn't get AIDS, but theycan't guarantee it.
You know, as much asmy mind says hey it's okay, my heart sayswell it may be okay, but I still don't know.
[Bobby:] You know I've never told my sisterthat she was wrong for being afraid,
but some of her fears are irrational andif she's going to continue being afraid
there's some day that I may die and she willnever have been able to cope with those fears.
[Narrator:] This woman was diagnosed with AIDS last year. She is addicted to heroin and believes she contracted
the disease through shared needles. She would notallow her name or voice to be used on the air.
But these are her words. [Female patient 2:] Well it hurts, you know, becauseyou're carrying around a burden. You know
what's going on and you can't let anybody knowabout it because you know if they know then you're
going to be an outcast. Well they're very hatefulabout it, "oh you got AIDS, don't get around me!"
Oh I got in-laws I wouldn't even think of lettingthem know, you know. That they're not stupid
people, they're not street people either. They'reintelligent college people.
That's the reason Idon't want to come on the media. I don't want toget nothing that will hurt my family.
[Larry Saxon:] The majorityof the clients I've worked with will not have anykind of media presentation done on them at all
and I don't blame them. I understand perfectlywell with the Larouche Initiative pending,
with that mentality floating around America,the potential quarantine, the potential lock-upmentality.
I certainly understand them wanting tobe secretive with their diagnosis.[ Male Patient 2:] Not only family
and friends of concern for me, but the concern andworry for themselves, you know and the very selfish
attitudes, you know. Then I hope you see this. [ Sean O'Neil:] That'sone great thing I must say about having AIDS,
is you can really get away with saying anything. [Woman:] Isthat right?   [O'Neil:] Yeah, like an old person or a child.
[Narrator:] Sean O'Neil, is a writer and a lecturer ondance. He is also performed professionally.
Last summer he made an appearance
with the dance troupe in Sapporo, Japan.
[Sean O'Neil] After about a week I started feeling, not feelingright and having mainly just difficulty breathing.
Thinking back on it now, I cannot believe that I kept kept dancing and kept working. It was
a matinee. It was an afternoon and I knewthat I couldn't do the performance because
in rehearsal, I couldn't finish the ballet,
on my own breath.  So I didn't know what to do.
One of the girls on the company's dadwas a doctor and he got us an oxygen tank.
As the music's beginning as, 'Rossini', is beginning,I hear them pull the plug on the oxygen. I
in the first movement I danced with fourdifferent women, four different times and
so I did have a couple of exits on the firstmovement. Where I would just run off stage and
immediately go under the the oxygen and tryto get my breath back before I went back out.
I would be under the the tank and and I wouldsee all of these little Japanese girls with
their, you know, all wide-eyed just
staring at me. Like you know, is this
how Americans have just to get througha performance? So I just was very numb
and then in a daze and just kind of you
know kind of floated my way through it.
On the flight home, there was the Newsweek and Timearticles about AIDS. I read this case history
of this guy who had had pneumonia and everysymptom that he had, I had. I went straight to
my doctor and he diagnosed me as having pneumoniaand AIDS, virtually there in his office on the spot.
[Carolyn, Sean's mother:] I didn't know that much about AIDS. I of coursehad heard about it. He was very very ill.
The first time he was hospitalized for two weeks andlooked for a while like he might not make it.
So all we were concerned about at that point, was toget him over the pneumonia and worried about the battle against AIDS later.
[Narrator:] Sean's family took turnsstaying with him. Friends have helped pay his rent.
Unlike most people with AIDS, he is free toconcentrate on his own thoughts and feelings.
[Sean O'Neil:] The reactions that I got from my friendsessentially saved me. [Sean and Friend:] "I should, I think
I should go for it."  [Sean O'Neil:] When you feel like you're closeto dying. You just, it's the most unbelievable, um, feeling.
You just don't have any time forany baloney. I really started reading an
awful lot and listening to tapesand meditating and all of that.
It makes you really look at your life and
at yourself and at your priorities and
what you value. It's nice, it's really
nice to to be liberated from a lot of that
stuff. A lot of the day-to-day um, you knowthings you think are important that aren't.
[Female Patient:] Nobody really knows where that sickness camefrom. Oh you know, they're just learning about
it. But you know, naturally they have to blame iton something. So they want to say, "oh you know, if
you're gay, you get it. You know. I'm no more gaythan flying to the moon and I got it, you know.
[Male Patient:] The beasties, the beasties, all ofus to some degree have the beasties.
You wake up in the middle of the night. How amI going to make my mortgage payment? Um, what
am I going to say to my boss tomorrow? I reallywould like a raise and I don't know what to say.
For me it's fear. When am I going to die? LastFriday, I started noticing a difficulty swallowing.
It got progressively worse over the weekend,to the point where I didn't want to eat and
then it became sort of painful all the time.So tomorrow morning I have to go in for
an endoscopy. Where they're going to insert
a tube down my throat into my esophagusand stomach to see what might be going on.
[Narrator :] Lynn Eubanks, is a pediatric nurse she alsovolunteers for the Shanti Project. She took
her training from Bobby Reynolds and is nowassigned to him as an emotional support counselor.
She went to see him when he was waitingto find out the cause of his sudden pains.
[Lynn Eubanks:] I was real scared. I didn't, I didn't wantit to be the start of a decline. Which
Bobby's done without for four years. I know that that day will probably come. But
I didn't want it to be now. I
won't want it to be whenever it is.
"Hi look at you," you're getting
ready for the party. [Bobby:] I am.
[Narrator:] The initial test results were a surprise and arelief the pains appeared to stem from an ulcer.
[Lynn Eubanks:] Look great. [Bobby Reynolds:] That's all I've been
doing actually since I got over the
the shock of it was laughing. When I callpeople to tell them that all the test results were
negative and that they're treating me for an ulcer.They all say, "oh great it's only an ulcer,"... [Chatting] [Lynn:] We're done.
[Narrator:] At about the same time Bobby Reynolds became sickthis summer,  Sean O'Neill contracted pneumocystis
pneumonia for the second time. His mother, Carolyn, flew to San Francisco from the East Coast for
the three week duration of his treatments. [Carolyn:] Hewas doing quite well until he had the sinus
operation. Which kind of knocked him down andand put them wide open for the pneumonia again.
But we'll get through this one too. I'll
see you upstairs. [Sean:] Okay, all right boys. [Carolyn:] Good luck.
[Chatting] [Carolyn:] To wake up every morning and know you have to go
in there. The veins are getting more and more
sore. They're starting to roll. They can't getit with the first try and it's just terrifying.
Last night he was extremely upset,
thinking about two more weeks of this
and so I wanted to ask you is there any
possibility of shortening the treatment or
is that out of the question? [Dr. Stephen Mihalko:] I would not recommendit, because if we do a shortened treatment there's
a very high possibility that will get a relapse.
[Narrator:] Dr. Stephen Mihalko, treats both Bobby Reynolds and
Sean O'Neill. [Dr. Stephen Mihalko:] So if we want to really treatthis and try to keep it at bay for a while,
then we really should finish a standard
course of treatment and not cut any corners.
[Carolyn:] He's so good about this. That you can'tbe any less than he is. You can't be
a whimpering fool and you have to
forget your own pain and your own
fear and help him deal with his,
because he's the one who's sick.
Elevator floor]
[Nurse, tapping and looking for vein]
[Sen O'Neil:] You just do what you have to do to get through it.
The intravenous treatments were they, were horrible!
[Carolyn:] The first time we just thought, well we'redifferent we're going to lick this thing. He's
you know, the other patients seemed so tired andthere was a resigned look in their eyes that just...
We said well this isn't going to be us youknow. Now as time goes on, you start to
understand how difficult it is to live
with this thing month, after month and um.
Sean, said he can understand now, why anyonejust doesn't want to fight it anymore. [Narrator:] While
treating Sean O'Neill for pneumonia, Dr. Mahalkawas running further tests on Bobby Reynolds.
His ulcers were not as benign as they appeared.
[Dr. Mahalka:] Well actually it did turn out to be herpes. We got
a culture report back yesterday and started him onanti-herpes medicine, uh, in an oral form. It can be
serious and that can spread to other areas. But themain part of this is, it's associated usually with
an incredible amount of pain and people are notable sometimes to even swallow their own saliva.
[Bobby Reynolds:] So here it is now like a week and a halfafter that started and I'm feeling pretty good.
But I'm still having fevers at night
and I'm starting to have night sweats.
[Narrator:] Until last year Bobby counted on his loverMark, to see him through the bouts of sickness.
and the fear of dying from AIDS. They had beentogether for eight years but Mark died last fall.
[Bobby Reynolds:] Mark, Mark, Mark, he had his goodpoints and bad points as we all do.
He was a little arrogant. He was very
strong-willed about certain things.
But we had fun.
[Narrator:] When Bobby was diagnosed in 1982, Mark, wasapparently healthy. But in April of 1985 he too
was diagnosed, struck by cancer and a debilitatingparalysis the disease progressed quickly in Mark.
[Mark:] I truthfully admit that I miss being ableto go to restaurants and go to a movie. I mean I'm
just not mobile enough to do that and those thingsare still important. I want to work, you know. I want
to go in my kitchen and cook. I want to be able tohelp him work on the backyard... [Bobby:] When I tried
to prepare myself as much as possible because Iknew his death was inevitable. But you really can't.
He went into respiratory failure and he had donethat twice before. So I called just automatically
for the ambulance, the paramedics. But he wasgone. He was the most important person in my life
for a long time. I think that says it all foranybody no matter what your sexual preference is.
You have somebody in your life that's themost important person, That's who he was,
is.
What's next?
So I'll live it and I'll breathe it and I'll
eat it for so long and then I'll say, "break time."
You know, let's, let's go blow bubbles.
Let's go read a murder mystery or
let's just unplug the phone and
forget about it. Luckily I can do that.
[Narrator:] Most people with AIDS don't have the help andsupport counted on by people like Bobby Reynolds
and Sean O'Neil. This man is a constructionworker with ARC or AIDS-related conditions.
He was diagnosed while serving a prison term lastyear. [Construction Worker:] Well their reaction was medieval. The deputies,
coming by myself, peering in the window callingme a disease carrier. Uh, you know, like I
said. They're just, their whole overall attitudeis very medieval, you know. It's like a witch or
something, you know. What the hell? [Narrator:] When hearrived in San Francisco, this man went to
the AIDS Foundation which assigned social workerLarry Saxon to the case. Saxon's job is to help
people with AIDS and ARC get out of the worst ofsituations. [Larry Saxon:] they may have an AIDS or ARC diagnosis
and they also are suffering from alcoholism anddrug addiction. It's the most unpopular population
you can possibly imagine. A lot of those guysare also racial minorities. [Narrator:] The AIDS Foundation
rents apartments at undisclosed locationsto house destitute people with AIDS. While
they try to arrange for social security, medicaland a place to live. [Larry Saxon:] Their lovers throw them out.
Landlords throw them out. Friends, roommates, decidedthey can't live with them anymore because they're
afraid that they're going to come down with AIDS. Because they're sleeping under the same roof with
them. Which is insane! But people cater to thatpsychology of fear. They tend to go a little crazy.
[Male quoting movie:] "D-mil, I'm ready for my close-up. Oh yes." [Larry Saxon:] They'reall very independent, extremely independent. Most of
them have not been on welfare before. [Same male who quoted movie:] Don't worryabout it. If it don't kill you it'll make you fat.
[Man in the crowd:] Well, here at the Mill Valley Rotary Club. [Introducing Presenter:] Todaywe're honored to have with us as our speaker Dr.
Mary Reddick, who is the executive director ofthe Marine AID Support Network. [Narrator:] As AIDS spreads
beyond the commonly known risk groups, gay men andintravenous drug users. All segments of society
have a stake in learning about the disease. Thefact that the AIDS virus is only transmissible
sexually or through the blood is not alwaysreassuring news. [Dr. Mary Reddick:] One of the things that I learned
in doing AIDS work, was I learned that there'sno such thing as a closed sexual boundary.
About half of the gay men in the United States,sleep with a woman at least once a year. We run
the hotline at the Marine Aid Support Network andwe know the kind of the level of fear. [Woman Patient:] I was in the
hospital. I'll never forget, this a nurse was taking meout and I didn't have the sickness then. Walking me
down and saying mean things about homosexualsand how they got the sickness and how they,
you know, "God's punishing them." I said to myself,damn and she goes, "well I go and take care of these
patients." But she has no feeling for them and Ithought what if she was at my bedside when I was
dying and didn't have no compassion and thoughtI should be punished? But I've been dead, you know.
[Narrator:] The epidemic has become a political phenomenon.Candlelight Memorials in San Francisco and
elsewhere have turned into rallies againstdiscrimination AIDS is a frightening disease.
But to those who have it, public opinionis frightening and threatening as well.
[Bobby Reynolds:] People's fears are real. But they may notunderstand what my lifestyle is like. But
they understand that I'm a person.
That I'm hurting. So that they don't
send me off, to help just because I'm
a gay man or just because I have AIDS.
Together the citizens of San Francisco willcontinue making a difference together. Together,
my friends, together for we are a family and we arenot alone. Keep looking for the rainbows. Thank you.
Narrator: The AIDS virus has already claimedmore than a thousand San Franciscans.
Thousands more will join the
unwilling ranks of, 'those people'
before there is even hope for a cure. [Bobby Reynolds:] With us inthis moment of healing you may say the names of
those who have died or those who are now livingfor whom your heart hurts. Let us begin first
with the names of the three men who began thiscandlelight march three years ago, Bobby Campbell (we open our hearts),
William Calderon (we open our hearts) and Jerry Luponey
Richard (we open our hearts). ...
you